[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's in our blood
we're loud and we're proud everything we
do we're passionate about
we go hard and we find a way to get it
done
the second you get a whiff of this sport
the second you get a chance to watch or
play this sport you will be hooked being
hispanic being latino we love sport and
hockey is that next sport for us
this is one of the more undertold story
events in hockey it's a tournament that
uh invites uh hockey teams from latin
american countries like argentina
brazil in 2019 they invited jamaica this
year they had a bonus team in lebanon
from the middle east there's people that
believe that latinos don't want hockey
but we have people from all over latin
and central america who've paid their
own way to say
we want to play all these countries are
are playing for for pride for fun but
also for the future of ice hockey in
their countries the majority of these
countries with the exception of mexico
don't have ice rinks the opportunity
should be available to everyone and
that's really what motivates me is
creating memories for them and
experiences that otherwise they would
not have
for me it's very special in 2018 otero
opened the opportunity for the first
time to stay in the ice hockey and for
us and my team is awesome our focus is
latin america and the caribbean and
growing the game but the goal is to keep
the doors open for everybody
i was raised in a caribbean household
and it was something that i you know i
took pride in that's why i want to be
involved and come together and you know
have all these different countries from
chile to puerto rico to jamaica and come
together through sport is is really the
most beautiful thing
[Applause]
the fact that they were playing hockey
on ice is incredible to them and you
know this year we have the stanley cup
here and that's just like
a dream come true for so many of these
players that i just can't wait to see
their expressions
the second i heard of juan carlos
building this hockey tournament it was
just a sense of pride that i needed to
get to know this guy i needed to meet
him i needed to understand him we break
the barriers down so these kids don't
have to do it anymore sport is for
everyone
growing up cuban american in chicago
there weren't people that looked like me
or sounded like me
i felt i was living a dual life and
hockey really let me navigate and sport
was my equalizer
montoya reads it sees it stops it being
the first cuban american to play in the
national hockey league it's something
that i never took lightly and when you
sit around a room and you only see you
know 30 people from minority backgrounds
in nhl and you wonder why aren't there
more representation means a lot i think
in order to have
heroes or someone to look up to you have
to see them first that's the reason i'm
here today so those kids could see
someone like themselves
in a position
on the ice and also off the ice working
within the game of hockey i'm one of
those kids i'm a 52 year old former
hockey player i'm croatian jamaican i
grew up in jamaica my parents had no
idea what hockey was
but to assimilate amongst all my friends
they said hey why not try this we've got
to do the same thing we've got to tell
people we want you we got to speak their
language we have to be culturally
relevant there's so many things we have
to do and not just think if we build
something and say it's available that
people are going to show up
i feel like the more this tournament
grows and there's more exposure that
they're going to have opportunities to
build a rink in these countries because
i really feel that investments need to
be made what started out with like six
nine teams has grown 29 teams this
tournament next year juan carlos is
envisioning having a sub-saharan african
division he's created a monster
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a very festive atmosphere
there's definitely a soccer vibe here
they're cheering they're singing they're
really proud to represent their
country's colors we're familiar we're
here to represent our country and our
family our friends our teammates not a
lot of people know that we have a
women's hockey team so it's good for us
to show that we have uh two teams it's
an honor for me to represent my team and
my country at the same time for this
tournament
this is important because it is it's
spreading the game of hockey everywhere
it's giving people opportunities who
don't have the opportunities in their
countries to play hockey and it's just
it's fun for everyone
they know hockey they know the nuances
of hockey they know the plays you know
there's bragging rights they're talking
smack but there's also this commonality
of that we're all in this together
trying to build something that people
think does not exist and they're
shattering mess it's been an amazing
week being able to play with people who
look just like me who have the same
culture like me now we get to show off
that puerto rico and hockey is a thing
what's happening now is we start
including more and more players
because the more we grow the more we
diversify
the more beautiful this game will become
hockey is for everyone that this game
knows no geographic boundaries there's
no racial boundaries i believe this is
the best sport in the world
and the more we grow and the more we
include everybody
the best players yet to be born
foreign